حوادث الطائرات دائما اخبارها وصورها
ومقاطعها بتجذب انتباه الناس وفي حتى صارت
مساء الجمعه في كوريا مقاطعها واخبارها
واصله كل العالم
اللي شفناها الطائره كوريه جنوبيه في رحله
داخليه وهي جالسه بتهبط جيم واحد من
الركاب وفتح بابها فتح الباب وهي لسه في
الجو مثل مو شايفين الطياره كانت على
ارتفاع 700 قدم يعني تقريبا 210 امتار او
اكثر شوي وبعدها عاش الركاب ثلاثه دقائق
من الرعب لغايه ما هبطت الطياره بسلام
اكثر من 200 شخص كانوا علامتنا ولحسن الحظ
الاصابات كانت بسيطه يعني السلطات قالت
انه 12 شخص معظمهم مراهقين وطلاب نقلوا
للمستشفى لاصابتهم بمشاكل في التنفس
واوجاع في الاذن واصابات اخرى وكلهم
غادروا المستشفى بعدين بصحه جيده الطلاب
كانوا جزء من مجموعه رياضيين في طريقهم
لبطوله السلطات سارعت فورا وقبضت على
الشاب اللي فتح الباب ومثل مو شايفين
امامكم الرجل ما كان في حاله طبيعيه وخلال
القبض عليه كان يردد او يعني بيقول لي
الاطفال انه انا اسف يعني يبدو قصدو
الطلاب اللي كانوا في الطياره وانصابوا
وهذا الشيء اكدته السلطات اللي كشفت انه
اول ما قبضت عليه ما كان من الممكن
استجوابه لانه حالته النفسيه والعقليه ما
كانت تمام لكن لاحقا قدروا يستجوبوا وطلع
عمره 33 سنه وقال انه شهر فجاه بالاختناق
هو انه يبغى ينزل بسرعه من الطياره فقام
وفتح الباب وقال انه شعر انه الرحله طولت
جدا وانه الطيار كان بيسوق ببطء جوجل كمان
انه بيعاني من التوتر ونفسيته تعبانه بسبب
طرده من عمله مؤخرا للعلم بس الطياره كانت
في رحله داخليه من جزيره
جيجو في الجنوب لمدينه ديغو والرحله كلها
هذه على بعضها مدتها ساعه عموما السلطات
مثل ما قلنا ما زالت قابضه عليه وما افرجت
عنه خوفا من هروبه وبيواجه حاليا عقوبه
بالسجن ممكن توصل مدتها لعشره سنوات
واتهمه انتهاء قانون امن وسلامه الطيران
بعيدا عن الحادثه هذه تحديدا واللي صار
فيها في كميه اسئله عند الناس يعني وحول
العالم ما هي طبيعيه على هذا الموضوع
اولها يعني كيف ممكن اصلا باب طياره ينفتح
بهذه السهوله وفي الجو كمان يعني وهل
معجزه انه ما احد اصيب باذى حقيقي او
اصابه خطيره شركه الطيران اللي الرحله
تابعه لها هي شركه اسيانا والشركه اعلنت
انه ابتداء من اليوم راح توقف امكانيه حجز
مقاعد الطوارئ اللي هي عند المخرج والباب
في بعض طائراتها وما راح يتم حجز هذه
المقاعد حتى لو الطياره مليانه وهذا اجراء
احترازي للسلامه احنا معانا من القاهره
الكابتن طيار وخبير السلامه الجويه النائب
محمود القط اهلا فيك معانا طبعا انت دائما
تعرف قد ايش انا محبه لعالم الطيران وقديش
عندي دائما حاله خوف مستمر من هذا النوع
من الاخبار فتخيل لما اعرف انه راكب يقدر
يقوم يفتح باب الطياره يعني انا اعتقدت
انه باب الطي اره يعني صعب ينفتح شيء ثقيل
وكبير يعني
مساء الخير على حضرتك وعلى كل الساده
المشاهدين وفي سلسله من حالات الرعب اللي
عند حضرتك وحالات الاطمئنان اللي بنعملها
دايما ان شاء الله
حضرتك
خليني اطمن حضرتك وكل الساده المشاهدين
اولا الحدث ده حدث عارض حدث من الصعب ان
هو يحصل بكل ظروفه اللي حصلت فيه اولا
خلينا نقول شويه معلومات مهمه الطائره من
321 وهذا الطراز طراز حديث جدا اي لمس لاي
نوع من الابواب في الطائره بيظهر تلقائيا
وبسرعه عند الطيار في قمره القياده
الطائره ايضا كانت في مرحله الهبوط كانت
لا تتجاوز حوالي 300 متر من 200 متر من
على سطح الارض يعني حوالي 300 قدم وهنا في
هذه المرحله واثناء الهبوط تكون الطائره
في سرعه ابطا سرعات لها وهي في الجو وده
امر مهم ان احنا نتكلم عليه ان السرعه
البطيئه هي اللي ساهمت في فتح الباب بسرعه
يعني الراكب لما مجرد ما سد المقبض بتاع
التيار الباب وفتق وزق الباب فتحه اتفتح
معاه بسرعه لان السرعه هنا كانت بطيئه جدا
نظرا لاقتراب الطائره من الارض واقترابها
من الهبوط التيار طبعا تعامل مع الموقف
باحترافيه شديده جدا ان هو استكمل الهبوط
لانه كان قريب من الارض الامر لم يستغرق
اكثر من بضع ثواني مش دقائق وان هو يكون
على الارض طبعا هنا في حسن حظ مهم جدا ان
احنا ننوه ليه ان هذه المرحله
لركاب جميعا بيكونوا رابطين احزمه المقاعد
وجالسين الجلوس الصحيح في الطياره
ومستعدين للهبوط وده اللي ساهم مساهمه
شديده جدا ان ما يحصلش عندنا اي اضرار على
التيار طب بس عشان افهم كلامك صح يعني
عشان افهمك كويس الان اذا الطياره كانت في
وضعها الطبيعي اللي هو وضع الطيران في
ارتفاعها العادي خلال الرحله
الباب ما يقدر ينفتح
كان هيكون من الصعوبه الشديده ان هو يفتحه
بالشكل اللي هو عمله به كان هيكون بصعوبه
شديده جدا وكان اكيد ان احد يعني افراد
طاقم الضيافه كان هيلحقوا قبل ما يفتحوا
لسبب مهم انه بمجرد لمسه للمقبض بتاع
الباب بتاع الطياره كان هيظهر بسرعه قدام
قائد الطائره اللي كان هيوجه احد الضيافه
دي بسرعه جدا طب انا جدا مقلق بالنسبه ليا
الموضوع انه يكون في راكب حتى لو نحن على
مسافه قريبه من الارض عارف يفتح الباب
يعني انا بصراحه بشوف الطياره انهم بيجوا
مجموعه كده وبيضغطوا الباب وبيكون في احد
واقف من برا وكده يعني هذا كيف كده قام
فتح الباب وخلصنا يعني
هو الحقيقه ان الباب فعلا باب بيكون تقيل
جدا بيكون صعب جدا فتحه وخصوصا ان حتى في
هذه المرحله مرحله الهبوط والسرعه بطيئه
دفع الباب امر صعب جدا وهذا يمكن بيؤكد
شكوكي الشخصيه في تحليل الموقف ان ان هذا
الراكب عارف كويس الباب بيتفتح ازاي وعارف
قوه الدفع اللي لازم يدفع بها الباب وعارف
المرحله اللي يقدر يفتح فيها الباب بقوه
وسرعه فانا اعتقد ان التحقيقات هتطلع يعني
اسرار اكتر في تحقيق لهذه الحادثه يعني
طيب هل هي مثلا هذه حادثه يعني نادره
الحدود ولا ولا لا ما شاء الله في كثير
ركاب بيحبوا يعني ينزلوا ابدر من الطياره
من الباقي يعني ما شاء الله عليهم
لا لا لا هي نادره الحدوث جدا وغير متوقعه
ويتكاد تكون يمكن الاولى في هذه المرحله
المتعارف عليه عاده ان الراكب اثناء
الطيران في الرحله ممكن يخبط مقود المقبض
بتاع الباب باي شكل وبيظهر عند الطائره
والضيافه بتتوجه له لكن في هذه المرحله من
الهبوط لا هي فعلا غير معتاده وجديده
واعتقد ان هي هيكون لها تحليل في النظم
السلامه الجويه للتعامل معها فيما بعد
يعني طيب شفنا قبل فتره الجريبه اللي هو
كسر الشباك
يعني ده كان حادث يختلف شكلا وموضوعا ده
كان راكب ظروفه تختلف عن هذا الراكب اللي
عندنا وخلينا نطمن الناس برضه شباك
الطائره مش شريحه واحده هو بحد ادنى بيكون
ثلاث شرائح يعني هو شريحه خارجيه وشريحه
وسطه وشريحه داخليه يعني كسر الشباك من
الداخل لا يؤثر على سلامه الطائره ولا
يؤثر على الضغط داخل الكابينه لكنه طبعا
اجراء غير طبيعي ويجب التعامل معه الخطوط
الان انه ما تجلس اي احد عند خلينا نقول
اللي هم الكراسي اللي عند الاكزيتس او عند
المخارج الطارئ
يعني اجراء احترازي طبعا الشركه خدته ولكن
اعتقد ان هي هترجع فيه في الفتره القادمه
ممكن يكون لها اجراءات احترازيه اخرى هو
نوع من انواع الاطمئنان للراكب اللي هيقعد
على الاجراءات اللي تخص هذا الراكب لكن ان
يفقده هذا المقعد لفتره طويله احنا بنتكلم
على اقتصاديات الطيران اللي مهم ان هي
تشتغل بالطريقه المثلى ولكنه اجراء
احترازي وسوف يتم تعديله لاحقا بعد اختيار
يعني بعد وضع بعض الاجراءات الاحترازيه
الاخرى يعني الراكب بيتم تلقينه ان هو
هيقعد جنب وبالمناسبه الراكب اللي بيختار
ان هو يقعد جنب باب المخرج الطوارئ او
الاكزيت بيختار ايضا بعنايه اثناء الحجز
يعني هو لازم يكون له مواصفات خاصه بيتعمل
له تلقين من الضيافه ان لا قدر الله في
حاله الطوارئ يعني الاجراءات 1 2 3 فهو
ليه ليه اجراءات خاصه هذا المقعد بالذات
يعني الله يستر علينا ان شاء الله جميعا
وان شاء الله دائما نركب الطيارات يعني مع
ناس اسوياء نفسيا وعقليا وكل شيء او
الامور تكون تمام نحن بنشكرك على هذه
المداخله كان معنا من القاهره الكابتن
طيار وخبير السلام الجويه النائب محمود
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]